guys I'm so excited to be back on the
road with the Jokers and you can get
tickets right now and in Practical
jokerslive.com half the cities are
announced as like 40 or 50 cities on
there and practicaljokerslive.com this
coming weekend will be in North
Charleston Charlotte Waterloo New York
and Washington DC uh in March we're in
Niagara Falls Big Show in Newark New
Jersey a home show at Prudential Center
uh Wallingford Connecticut and also the
UBS arena in Long Island we are so
psyched that's a new Arena it's
beautiful can't wait to play it later on
in March Green Bay Milwaukee Rosemont
Illinois then we move on to Seattle
Portland Boston uh Utah Denver Arlington
all a bunch of Texas a bunch of Ohio all
the dates are on there right now uh the
show is so much fun it's new it's fresh
it's 100 new material it's interactive
it's pretty crazy we do some crazy stuff
at this show you're gonna really love it
so I'm excited to be on the road I just
finished my tour this is the new one in
practicaljoyslive.com folks Joe to Rosa
here here I got some live dates coming
up gonna be in Baton Rouge on March 9th
gonna be Lafayette March 10th March 11th
New Orleans those are all in Louisiana
March 22nd I'm back at the crane theater
doing the one man show I Never Promised
You a Rose Garden that's also the show
I'll be doing on the road at all these
dates unplugging right now March 30th
Amtrak Michigan uh Grand Rapids on the
31st of March April 1st Chicago Illinois
uh Batavia Batavia Illinois I don't know
how to say it uh April 2nd and then
Columbus Ohio April 21st and 22nd and I
think we're adding a date for Stamford
Connecticut in there as well in April
all kinds of dates coming up come check
me out I want to see you out there all
tickets and show info are available at
jodarosainfo.com and come to Joey Rose's
sandwich shop and bar if you're in New
York City open seven days a week at 11
30 a.m ever every day we've got
sandwiches new old drinks all kinds of
stuff you know the deal come on out
folks all right I'll see you later taste
buds they come into the mic talking
about the food they hate talking about
the food they like two Fool's gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
them hey taste buddies and Tasties
welcome to
t-a-s-t-e buzz
good to see you buddy yeah yeah it's
good energy today it is it's a sunny
afternoon it is unseasonably warm it is
I like your outfit I like your color
story thank you the color stories are
big for me I mean we gotta I got a nice
match going on today because the orange
pops off the pants and the cream pops
off the sneaks and it's an exact match
that I like that the the sock is where
you're going flashy but it ties
everything together where are the socks
from
I feel like I got him through somebody
that sponsored us
really I feel like I picked these off of
a website
I don't remember but that's like one of
those companies that would say like okay
we have shirts underwears and socks yeah
yeah pick something are they bombas they
might be all right shut up bombas either
way shout out bombers either way and by
the way r.i.ps to uh uh Dave from De La
Soul that's a raw dude you don't even
know it's terrible dude you don't even
know man yeah I was uh I'm supposed to
go to the uh that streaming release to
album release party at Webster Hall on
March 2nd I got invited and I was gonna
get to meet the like meet Tim and then
what a what if what 54 whatever I know I
mean it's so goddamn said it's I mean
anyone but like I loved soul man I know
I love them all their all their albums
are finally going to streaming uh and
talk about just like a like a luminous
like just a guy like like a guy that
like I never met well no I did meet him
I booked daily so I duck Dale I saw at
my college and I I was like the it was
like my student it was my event so I
booked them and I got to meet all of
them oh wow and they were really really
cool all three of the dudes were really
really cool but Long Island baby yeah
just just dudes that have like light
coming off of them like they were just
so positive and just yeah they're on
that island of their own in hip-hop for
me like they're
I mean I love all Native tongues you
know but yeah yeah but they are just
they're just was different and in that
time when when three feet high and
Horizon came out you know and then De La
Soul Is Dead all that stuff they were
just there was I don't really know many
people that were like them you know that
you're right that whole native tongue
thing is great like so it's that's where
I'm that's where I live
de la tribe
Black Sheep
the beat nuts which I never knew till
recently were part of native I didn't
know that we got jungle Brothers
in there well wait no Queen Latifah's
Flavor Unit no but she was made of
tongues bro I don't think she was
well I spoke to her about it oh you did
oh oh oh I'm sorry well when I I was on
our show and I was like I'm native
tongues all the way and like she better
have been native tongues did she say I'm
native tongues she said of course you'd
come on here and drop native tongue
zombie like well but
can you just uh tell me who's in the
native tongue she might have just been
given you know I'm pretty sure she was
in it boo
she was the head of the Flavor Unit yeah
but I think that's post
I hope I'm not wrong
she was she was a native damn it oh I
wanted to be right about that
who else was in Native tongues pimp do
you got the whole list there there's not
too many more jungle Brothers
um
run it
God man that wait a minute
that probably explains when they did the
50 years of hip-hop tribute on the
Grammys when dala did Buddy it was just
past the news yeah and I was like why is
it just positives like what the hell man
I wonder if that's related to his
passing man we were one I was wondering
oh God man that's so sad man well dude
shouts out to you thank you for
everything you gave us what a body of
work what an amazing Legacy and what a
guy that will be remembered in nothing
but positive uh yeah we have fans that
don't know that never listen to De La
Soul check out their music it's going to
be streaming it's only March 3rd yeah do
yourself a favor I mean I'm almost
jealous if you've never checked it it's
like the shades the shades that they go
through on the different records it's
just it's so cool man yeah like it's so
fun to to see the approach to each
records every record is different yeah
that's one thing they did yeah yeah yeah
it's great yeah
uh take it take it take it you're gonna
you're doing that is that why you kept
that there were you doing that on air or
no you wouldn't open no it's not really
related but it's like
it's parallel something okay it's really
it's it's it feels nice it's been two
months I I got you that I I saw that and
I picked it up and I I never gave it to
you I by the way I just remembered
I can't believe I didn't think of this I
just remembered the sitcom we were
talking beforehand about doing an
episode where we do sit Converses yeah I
just remembered the sitcom I'm gonna
take to your face oh
how did I not think of this how do you
know I don't like it I don't care if you
do because you don't like it as much as
I do
Frasier baby uh of course you got the
tattoo and everything free well I didn't
get it yet Oh I thought you had a
Frasier do you have the skyline no I'm
waiting for somebody to do it for me for
free oh okay
Frazier we should do Frazier versus
Seinfeld because Fraser reboot is about
to drop
with who Kelsey reboot well well like
like a new seat like they're not with
David is David uh Alan Pierce it's
Kelsey Grammer
Frasier they didn't say that's passed
David had David David Hyde Pierce is not
coming back he said he said he just
didn't want to revisit it the story is
he's going back to Boston is the
storyline and it's his new life in
Boston
I don't know if I'm supposed to say this
or not but I read the Bible
I read it and it's great
that was the king of the he that that
was at the top for a while right Frazier
it was he was winning every video babe
it was David Seinfeld
so anyway Frazier's about so new season
of Fraser is about to drop on Paramount
Plus in a few months or whatever
I'm excited for it
what I know about it is really good
really funny and
I'm gonna do I'm gonna do Frasier and
you're gonna take Seinfeld and we're
going to battle
oh wow I mean I think Seinfeld will win
that but I think they might I never
thought I really have a Frasier is a
dark horse I mean Frasier's yeah he's
just really really good and it's not
always in the conversation no you know
all right
we got we know our next step all right
all right you know what's next I was
thinking of that he sings the he sings
the uh yeah
the theme song yeah I I was singing it
in my head while you were talking and
then it made me think of another theme
song which I think is also a top-notch
at least theme song If you don't like
the sitcom Mr Belvedere
uh I'm not a huge fan of the show as
much as I am a fan of Bob Uecker sure uh
but I don't remember the theme song I
always want to it's so funny every old
sitcom from that time period where I
can't remember the theme song I
immediately go to the get to the Gary
Shandling show song sure which you sang
and somebody animated yes oh shout out
to uh those guys shout outs uh is it
cartoon or radio yeah those guys we love
them uh yeah so the the Mr Belvedere is
uh
[Music]
no no that's that's Shanley isn't it
yeah Randy Newman is shamling and then
sometimes things get turned around and
no one's there yeah according to our new
arrival life is more than me or
surviving
about a good life yet helped him that's
Belvedere Blossom is the is what's his
face
foreign
I would have sample this to make a
hip-hop beat out of it
yeah wait but but who said what not
Randy new who's no no Blossom is a
brother whatever is okay let me ask you
a question wait wait no no don't stop
drinking who sings The Blossom song bro
it's that guy brother whatever
Brother Wolf
no Dr uh doctor oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah doctor what is it yes
Dr Judd
oh man Jesus this is wait who sings the
Belvedere song
I don't know but I like that blur so
what is what is opinionation
that's the docs Dr John but did he make
up that word yeah like in my opinion
Nation him and Randy Newman would do
[__] like that because look he says
opinionation's also like Creole whatever
so it's probably like a creole word oh
is it so opinion let me ask you a
question uh Mary J Blige if you watch it
now we know that you are speaking of
opinionation Queen what is it the queen
address the queen use the title I'm JB
the queen
speaking of opinionation it makes me
think of her what is hateration and
holleration does that have to do
whatever the hell she wanted it to me
well she's not from New Orleans yeah but
she doesn't want hateration or
holleration in this dance array and for
me that's a really unique sentence she
says that bro
don't want no
hateration in this dance swear to God if
you just I know the song now that you
put it in concert I like that song Dr
Dre I believe produced that song
but anyway
if you just told me that lyric yeah
just just straight without singing it I
wouldn't have been able to place it and
I would have bet my life that it was a
line
from Greece or something like like that
and this dancer yeah
yeah
oh you know all right are you good with
sitcom songs
well apparently I stink I'm you know I
think I got ready
we did this before we were sang them
yeah but I love them I can't I don't get
enough of them
um all right pimp please make a note of
Frasier versus Seinfeld and the reason I
brought up Frasier was because when you
gave me this yeah I thought of a great
line from Frazier from a Christmas
episode it's one of my favorite jokes
when uh Martin the dad says he picks up
a president he goes oh heavy or he goes
it's heavy this is a good one unless
it's a book
and I picked this up and I was like oh
this is heavy it does feel like a book
it's not a book I'll give you that
though it's a pair of sneakers
all right ready yeah yeah yeah it's it's
we don't need really it's it's I don't
want to be under over under well happy
birthday to pimp
happy birthday this is too pimp happy
birthday to pimp happy birthday dear
pimpy
Happy Birthday to you you thank you
speaking of hateration hollering in the
Pink Nation there was this show called
the white rapper show on VH1 that was
done by um it was done by uh I remember
MC search yeah yeah MC search shout out
MC search shout out to MC search but uh
I forgot the production company did uh
it's a like a pretty good hip-hop
company anyway there was this guy on
there named John Brown
and if you want to pull it up when he
first stepped up and they they were
trying to like they were just cast and
they had to cast them he had to step up
and say and he goes yo what's
pimpulating he says what's pimpulating
I'm John Brown the King of The Burbs
Hallelujah holla back little homie is
this white kid and it was so [__]
funny and he said what's pimpulating and
I to this day I never heard that and we
said me and my buddy Saint Oldham was
pimpulating and it's like pimp that's a
good like what's pimpulating it's
perfect for you it's like it's in the
vein of hateration holiday find a clip
of that and Sample right now John Brown
Put on John Brown uh white rapper show
It's the funniest I'll have to dig it
out there's only best doves here that
was an upsetting uh that was an
upsetting five years for me
the error of VH1 reality shows and
competition shows that were all starring
my favorite rappers and I just didn't
want to see them in that capacity
I just didn't it was and I'm not I'm not
knocking anybody by bringing up these
shows I'm still massive fans but it was
ice love Coco it was Flavor of Love It
was the it was iced tea had the rapper
competition show I remember it was the
um
just texted you the pimp it was uh it
was uh wait a minute there was another
one that were blanking on
wait wait Flavor of Love
oh white rapper show with MC sir I love
the white rapper show though I just it
was such a it ain't fun like seeing all
my favorite rappers I just wasn't into
it love seeing iced tea on SVU
didn't like seeing him in like a in like
that format I just didn't oh oh runs
house
I didn't watch any of that [__] but
white rapper show is not those shows
though it was it was react those reality
in competition shows were sort of all
loved together so how'd you feel about
the osbornes that pretty much started
the Kardashians I it's it's funny man
real world and yeah and real world and
then that they did that I hated the
osbornes I hated it like the osbornes is
something where I started like the shows
I'm naming now I was like uh I don't
like my favorite rappers in this format
The Osbournes I was like I kind of like
was like losing respect Ozzy it was like
hurting my image of Ozzy and I'm still a
fan seeing him hobbling around as a
house with a robe on with her dude I had
a joke in my act when the Osborne was
about how crazy it was that when I was
growing up people thought the like the
parent groups and everything that were
taken on yeah that they thought this guy
was the devil yeah like this guy like
with his like husky son you know getting
yelled at by his his tiny wife this is
who they thought the devil was it's so
crazy no it sucks I didn't know him
beforehand so I only knew him as that
and then visited the music and I was
confused utterly confused dude I mean
he's got you got he has some of the most
all-time bangers of all I mean oh dude
this Black Sabbath dude is his pipes the
Sabbath run with Ozzy and and look see
this is one of the best songs ever ever
I feel bad I hope he's doing all right
he just canceled everything forever yeah
it's a bummer Sabbath I got to see
Sabbath on the farewell tour which was
nuts but Sabbath's run with Ozzy is is a
Banger's Sabbath without Ozzy has some
bangers but then Ozzy's first one or two
without Sabbath are pretty righteous
records yeah you know uh the one with uh
with the Suicide Solution and Mr Crowley
what'd you think Mr Collier uh would you
think of the one uh Crowley's that uh
Victor Crowley
no not Victor Crowley what am I saying I
think Victor Crowley is named after the
song Mister it was the guy from it was a
tectonic guy right isn't it Mr Crowley
yeah I don't know was he the leader of
the he was like yeah I know I forget it
what would you think of the Leader Ford
song was it with Ozzy yeah I don't even
remember what it was if I closed my eyes
me neither not a fan just soon as you
started singing it I got haunting
visions of MTV yes yeah I wasn't a fan I
likely to Ford but there was nobody
hotter than Lita Ford in that period
when she was like post runaways hold on
heavy metal solo lady like like just
dancing around MILF territory like she
was the hottest [__] woman on the
planet maybe this won't count but I was
gonna throw at you Tony katine
dude babe are we connected are we
connected are we connected feel like in
the soul and brain are we why because
last night I did a deep dive on Tawny
why because I put bachelor party on when
I was going to bed no [__] yes wow yes
what are the odds I bring her up today
no no
it's crazy
yeah remember that Wild Thing video
dude of course man wait no no she's not
Wild Thing Jessica tan is wild thing oh
Bonnie was uh was uh the uh was it
Winger yeah no she's not Cherry she's
not cherry pie I know but no 20 no uh
White Snake yeah she's white chick yes
here she died
no I didn't know that yeah she died like
a few years ago oh no she's sad isn't it
Jesus yeah anyway I was watching sorry I
shouldn't go anyway we gave such a
beautiful tribute to to David De La Soul
tardy yeah shout outs thank you for all
you did yes she was she was and I I was
like MiMi says I was watching her in
Bachelor part I was God she was like so
like bubbly and fun yeah uh would you
think of uh Daryl Hannah and splash
you know Daryl Hannah she never did it
for me for whatever reason not even in
Splash even in Splash but I gotta tell
you Hanks didn't do it for do it for me
either he was you know he was no catch
no pun intended so
folks uh folks listen a lot of people
don't remember candy in that one either
candy I mean candy hits a Grand Slam in
that movie when he's the scene with
candy where he's purposefully dropping
penny so he can pick them up and look up
the ladies skirt and Tom actually comes
and he goes oh come on
think they're redoing that too they are
yeah with uh and uh and I'll hit this
I'll hit you with this microphone it
makes me so mad with a mer man
oh no
who it was supposed to be Channing Tatum
he walked he we apparently walked so you
know you know I don't know we'll see
what happens if he I see him as a merman
yeah but I just re-watched The Burbs
which is my favorite whatever Tom Hanks
movie uh and
and I love love love The Burbs and I
love Rick dukemen and The Burbs I think
he's awesome
but it is one of those things like they
did offer it to John Candy John Candy
said no because he was like I'm not
doing another movie where I play like
the fat guy
and uh
and I just I God I want to know what
that would have been like if it was him
and candy yeah but I mean do come in
knocks it out of the [__] Park you
know he's dead shout outs to Rick do
come in yeah Jesus man this isn't the in
memoriam episode of taste buds
speaking of death days
birthdays oh wait no this is Christmas
presents yeah it's it's it's it's a
really just because you've you've
downplayed the monetary value of this
gift to a point that I don't even know
if I want to open it anymore the
monetary value what is it could be of
Russell Stover's you better not have
wrapped it up
uh babe Russell stoves is too rich for
my blood it's a Whitman sample no
um no no no I don't know download
playing the monitor I'm joking I'm just
joking no but I'm joking no but I know
you are but it's but we didn't touch on
monetary no I I that's why it's a joke
you know what they say about jokes you
gotta explain but before before the
cameras rolled South they can go dude
it's nothing no because I did because
when I first told you like oh I I did I
was like no no it's not like that I I've
gotten this way in my older age there's
like three people in my life that
the gift exchange tradition has gone on
so long no matter what I'm just like no
I have to get them a gift this year I
have those but honestly I don't mind it
if I see something that any I reminds me
of any of you at any time I will get
that but that's where I'm at now with
all my friends or my other friend I'm
like if I see something that I think
works I'll do it you know what I mean
but you have to be struck by the
audience this might be risky you might
even
you might have this I don't know let's
see you know what I've never done you
know what I'm gonna do let's just keep
doing this and then don't ever open the
gift I'm gonna I'm gonna unwrap it fully
with my eyes closed
and then open my eyes okay all right all
right
I don't know what that does I don't know
either okay but then you guys can see it
okay
I mean it's definitely it's in line with
what we were talking about earlier
stop all right
it's definitely a book
wrong though wrong foreign
there's what feels like a book slip on
it I hope you like cigars
all right wait hold on hold on don't
open your eyes don't let me see the let
me see it hold on no I was gonna say if
it was raised the cover was raised you
might be able to feel it is that it
that's the front of it you're showing
the camera the front of it okay I mean
it's a book I can feel Pages now you'd
be surprised ready yeah
whoa dude yeah not only do I not have
this I didn't even know this existed I
didn't until I saw it yeah Mike's down
so is this a book about Dylan yeah man I
mean obviously yeah
but I mean no actually Ozzy
[Laughter]
but it's it's meaning like is it an
autobiography or is it like no I don't
know it's not an auto interview I mean I
mean not autobiography meaning yeah
about his life and times it is or is it
like okay it is okay it's just all about
his story everything that he did for
hip-hop God damn it another in memoriam
yeah yeah pretty much this is that
episode I guess Jesus shout out to Jay
Dillon but he's one of the best this is
wonderful man thank you of course thank
you this is so thoughtful and so like
I don't know anybody that would have
thought oh that that I should get him
that well I saw it and thought of you
that's what I mean like that that you're
a friend
what can I say you're a friend you're a
real friend
boom boom boom boom traveled down the
road and back again
the heart is true you're a pal and a
confidante
[Music]
and if you threw a party boom boom
anybody and everyone you knew boom boom
you would see the biggest gift would be
from me and the cards
bow
[Applause]
[Music]
ready
oh that's the opening that's oh that's
an opening yeah directed by Terry Hughes
yes yes shot of the house you got you
got can you name him first and last
names yeah I mean at this point everyone
the actresses well how about both
characters and and uh yes if I can I'll
be disappointed myself okay uh b b
Arthur as as Dorothy spornak yes Betty
White as Rosen Island yes uh um Rue
McClanahan yes as Blanche Devereaux who
I met who I think by the way I think
every one of them has passed this is
their in memoriam episodes yes yes I got
well I got another story about a past
okay I met Blanche Devereaux she was in
the audience at stand-up New York no she
was and when I got off stage Blanche
Devereaux was in the audience yes
she was in a stand-up New York what the
[__] was that's what everyone's thinking
uh what was Rue McClanahan doing at
stand-up New York anyway it's Sofia
Patrol I didn't forget no not Betty
White I'm sorry uh Estelle Getty um
that's it she just came into the club
with people and like to watch the show
she thinks she is and when I got off
stage she pulled I did crowd work and I
talked to her when I got off stage she
pulled me in and she said you're very
funny
isn't that wild I mean how many people
can say that I got one that tops it at
stand up New York again ready for this
ready for this can you give me a hint
another sitcom okay okay sitcom we've
mentioned today older actor today yep
older yep dad from Frasier nope okay
sitcom we mentioned today yep
Eubanks
no
okay
well it's not it's not Kelsey is it no
maybe it's not that show we've mentioned
other shows I know yeah you're right
David I'm kidding uh Mr President
what else did we just oh oh
now who from there though who from it
tell me it was uh uh it wasn't it wasn't
it wasn't Blossom herself no it was the
brother Joey no no older actor oh older
yeah yeah well I'm trying to get the
Golden Girls territory older oh all
right but what the [__] did we just what
do we talk about I'm blanking on this
now you're throwing me because now I'm
just trying to remember this I know
you're missing it's so it's so obvious
you're gonna be like
you want another hit yeah mail
um
significant older character from two
major sitcoms back to back
one of them was mentioned here on the
show today what are we talking about
similar character on both shows
I feel like I feel like a complete
failure famous father in real life
in real life a famous father
I feel like a real piece of [__] right
now this is actually not doing me any
good
I feel like terrible I I feel like I'm
blind I don't feel great I'm fully
blanking you those that with those Clues
we've talked about the sitcom he's in
two he's a famous father
plays a father on the sitcoms
how are you not kidding this I can't
believe you're not getting this
I can't believe you're you're not even
like I can't all we talked about was
Blossom Seinfeld Frazier yeah Mr
Belvedere okay let's see is it father on
Blossom
I don't remember who the father of
Blossom was old actor in The Golden
Girls range who played a dad on two
sitcoms it is a famous father in real
life
all right
but what sitcoms did we just talk about
that's all we did you just named them
okay so pick one of those Mr Belvedere
review Banks it's not no no Mr Belvedere
was Euchre oh Bob Eubanks
Kevin Eubanks from the tonight I meant
Bob Uecker no it's not Bobby it's not Mr
Belvedere it's not the father from
Frasier oh
Jerry Stiller yes
I mean that was yes that was easy yes
I got that
we were at state New York and everybody
was like there was this Buzz again state
of New York you got a cobble it from
Jerry ready for this buddy this is
better than a compliment ready for this
everybody's like all the goat there's
like a buzz like Jerry Stiller's coming
in to watch the show Jerry Stiller is
coming in to watch the show who's on the
show he's coming for he just wanted to
come watch stand up which I can explain
after the story it'll make sense he just
wanted to come watch show so everybody's
like all a buzz like he's coming in he's
coming in make sure when he gets here
you what you're in comedy with you
probably around a 10-year Mark somewhere
in there nine years like not that far in
and um did you have your half hour
already
uh you had I either I either you had an
act yeah yeah of course no I was doing a
weekend spot I mean no I either had my
half hour or I was on the precipice of
getting it okay but I was right half out
by the way I'll always tell you that
thank you very much up to this day and a
lot of [__] does not hold up that's
sweet thank you yeah so I was right in
that zone
he comes in and I had a really uh
aggressive joke about uh Jesus in my act
at the time it was very aggressive
and I was like I don't want to do it you
see the Jesus commercial in the Super
Bowl continues yeah it was crazy
at the end it was just like Jesus she's
a flash that's it yeah I was like what
is this even I don't even Flash trailer
in the Indiana Jones trailer set me like
spinning I was standing next to pimp
when it happened I was with the Rosa and
he goes I have goose yeah he said that
before I cracked up how great was that
at the cellar though when they showed
the Flash trailer when Keaton goes I'm
Batman the whole seller cheered it was
awesome it was that was so fun anyway
so I had this joke and I was scared to
do it in front of him and I was like
well he's Jewish he's not going to be
offended by a Jesus joke but he's not
he's a comedian he's not gonna be
offended at all well it was it was a it
was a harsh joke I wouldn't do the joke
now let's put it that way well we can't
wait to hear this joke I'm not gonna
tell the joke but what are you crazy
yeah you gotta tell it I don't fully
remember it I just remember do you
remember what was so hard I I think the
basic premise was like you can he uh
you can [__] on any
you could take the Savior out of
Jerusalem but you can't take the drugs I
think the concept was that you could
that you could make fun of any God and
any relent you everybody makes jokes
better but but if you no this is wrong
this isn't what it is it doesn't matter
it's all right put it to bed yeah but
anyway it was it was it was it was just
trust me you know that if I'm saying to
you it was harsh that it was harsh yeah
yeah anyway
I was like well he won't be offended on
behalf of Catholics I was like but he
he's going to think I'm some just young
foul-mouthed comic and he's from a
different time and and I was like I'm
not gonna do that joke and then I was
like
you know what no man I always do this
I'm gonna just do the joke and I'm gonna
take whatever comes with it because
that's it like I'm not gonna whatever
and dude I went up I did my set as was
and I [__] killed
I killed
and at the end of the show he he pulled
he came up to me and he's like young man
I'd like to speak to you and he took me
outside
and I was like
and he was like
he goes uh he goes you were very funny
this evening and I go thank you
so much I can't he goes he goes
everybody was good but you took chances
that no one else did oh man
yeah I just got him too that's sick and
then he goes and he goes he goes the
reason I'm here is because I'm getting I
want to get back into live performance
I'm looking for writers so still in the
mirrors yeah and he goes I'm looking for
writers and I go okay and he goes I'd
like to take your number
and call you I'm getting another wave of
Goosebumps
I swear to [__] God look at that
I could feel it I can feel it yeah so I
gave my number and he was like okay I'll
be in touch and I never heard from him
but he also I don't think ever did the
live performance thing and then he
actually passed away not soon after but
but like soon enough after that I was
like Ah that's a maybe he couldn't do it
and he would you know whatever it was
but
well this was 2000 I was I remember I
was living in Hell's Kitchen
so yeah it was about 10 years ago 2000
oh no but he didn't pass 10 years ago no
way
no he I think he died about five years
ago you know so um but but it was it was
uh it was yeah so so I don't know maybe
he just never I don't know or maybe he
did do it just didn't call me but anyway
uh that was that was that was insane
dude that was insane shout outs rest in
peace Jerry Stiller Andrew mcclenny when
can I tell you something embarrassing
I when I was younger and I was I was
doing sketch and improv and I did a
little bit of stand up and stuff but I I
just think the time where I thought I
wanted to be a filmmaker or at least a
screenwriter that's what I want to be
right so I would you know write some
scripts for Q I had you know I was I
wrote a couple of screenplays this and
that and at the time I I idolized uh
swingers at John Favreau yeah for making
swingers man he made that it was like
that whole 96 that independent boom with
clerks and all that stuff and it was
like we all wanted to write a swingers
yeah it was very accessible yeah they
did it on a shoestring budget they did
it like gorilla style uh and swingers
struck a chord with me at that time I
was going through a breakup I that was
my scene I love like at least I love I
really loved like Jasmine like it just
something clicked with me guys I saw
myself in those guys you know whatever
so I was like oh my God I loved it just
like just like everybody else right and
I put I put them up on a pedestal those
two guys right and I was in away and I
was again I was in my young 20s and I
happened to be um
gato was living out there and uh for a
while and he said to me one time he goes
he goes oh there's this place we were
thinking of where to go and he's like
this is placed by my house called The
Velvet Margarita
he's like um ever the last two times I
was in there I saw Vince Vaughn in there
so he's like we'll go hang out because
we're going to drink so we go my buddy
Brian Lynch she's a screenwriter
screenplay do you know Brian Lynch in
the viewer skew world but he now he's
written every single animated he wrote
minions and all that stuff
shout out Lynch I love you babe I'm
right I don't know yeah anyway anyway we
go for some drinks and we're sitting
there and I didn't say this story it's
you've told me the story off camera it's
a little bit embarrassing it's a little
bit embarrassing so he Joe tells me he's
facing the door he goes sorry not gonna
lose Vince Vaughn just walked in so I
was like get out here he goes oh and
John Farrow I was like stop it he goes
Enron Livingston I was like what come on
it's a cast of swingers walks in right
so I turn around I'm like oh my [__]
god it's a little later and they sit
down there's like 10 people they sit at
a long table with like two tables over
it turns out it was Vince's birthday and
he likes that place and they went to go
celebrate his birthday so I was freaking
the [__] out right here I am
I'm in California for a few days with
the odds I'm gonna run to them and I
would do anything to speak to them to
get advice from them to like just tell
them like you know right a maid came I
would love made to anyway so I didn't
know what to do
and I I was poor as [__] and I said can
I send him over should I send it we were
talking I sent him over a drink I don't
have any money you know like but how am
I gonna just send just him over a drink
for his birthday he's at a table of ten
yeah I was like and my friend's like you
gotta do it just do it so I was like all
right I'll buy the whole table drink I
guess check out my credit card that I
swear to God had like a 1500 all women
yeah yeah and how much is 10 drinks I
know I'm getting anxiety thinking about
it in L.A and I'm like I'm gonna take
the bullet I'm getting anxiety now right
right I I was like I don't know if it's
gonna get maxed out yeah yeah yeah and I
said can you please go to Vince tell him
uh happy birthday big fan we'd love to
buy the table around the drinks and I
was like I don't want to be I also don't
want to be that guy yeah you know like I
just don't I didn't know what to do but
I couldn't do nothing
she goes over to tell him and she comes
back she hands the card to me and she
goes I'm sorry he said he can't accept
and I was like oh my God I feel so bad
he goes no he just I I was crushing then
she goes no he just said like that's so
kind of you but he can't accept that
kind of generosity for me he appreciates
it so much that he'd love to buy your
whole table of drink wow so I was like
and then I looked and I go well I can't
accept that because like he just said am
I taking advantage and my Freddy Brian's
like you take that [__] drink right
so we were like four or five people on a
table so we buy around the drinks I
never forget I gotta Kettle and soda and
when we got it we turned and he was
looking and he put his drink up that's
so cool thank you very much for the
offer and I was like oh thank you man
happy birthday he's like cheers guys you
know thank you and I was like oh my God
all right that's so cool to this day I
drank I finished that drink and I have I
I stole the glass and it came in I have
a rocks glass in my kitchen right now
that's so cool that's so cool
so on the way out
um we we were just about just so
happened we were getting up when we were
finishing when they were finishing and
they all got up and I was like should I
say something and my friend's like well
now's the time they're just getting up
saying goodbye getting their coats so I
walked over Vince was talking to Ron
Livingston I walked over to Fat bro and
I just was like you know I just said I
dude I'm I'm you know my young 20s that
movie meant the world to me it made me
want to become a screenwriter like it's
just you know and he came from improv he
was at Chicago at i o and I'm like I was
in town doing improv doing a show at uh
at uh improv Olympic I think it was okay
whatever and so we bonded on that and
he's like oh and we started talking a
little bit about comedy and everything I
think it was just being nice to me yeah
it's great though but he gave me a
little bit of advice and on the way out
Vince was at the front door I said
thanks so much he said thank you I
walked out and I got so emotional that I
met them that I called my girlfriend at
the time to tell her and when I when I
went to go tell her I just started
crying and I was so I was so like I was
so taken and so like on a high from
meeting yeah if you ask me at that time
if you had a genie who would you want to
meet it would have been them yeah yeah
and the fact that he bought me a drink
they took a little time to talk to me it
meant so much and I literally I couldn't
believe it but I started crying and I
felt so I was like I can't believe I'm
crying my girlfriend's like no I get it
man that's awesome like it means a lot
it means like yeah so embarrassing I
don't know uh no it's awesome you were
saying Jerry still has said those things
to you and I remember I had that feeling
of like oh my God I can't believe yeah
so I took the time it's awesome fast
forward 20 years later and
through friends I meet Vince Vaughn and
I start he's he he hires me to do his
comedy vessel like five years in a row
yeah I end up having a kind of a
relationship with him yeah I got his
number and I would go we'd go to lunch
and I I couldn't believe that I became
friends with him he almost produced our
movie or the Impractical Jokers movie
and one of the iterations of it it fell
through but um I never told him I never
told him uh about that I was like a
little like I should tell him because I
didn't want to be that guy like I just
was like let's just no let's just have a
relationship based on that story I told
Bob Odenkirk when we in in between takes
on Better Call Saul of like when I was a
six-month open biker driving four hours
to Washington DC to see Mr show live and
him letting me and my friend into the
lobby out of the cold to meet them
afterwards and I was like and hey dude
now and it was like the third season I
had done the show but it was the first
time I ever did a scene with him and I
was like just kind of wild just I'm now
I'm doing the show with you yeah and and
two takes later he had to be great he
goes like he he to take two full takes
later he goes
that's so [__] cool man and he
high-fived me he's like you did it dude
like and it was cool it was really cool
like he would love that story dude the
first time we got to get to the battle
but I gotta yeah where are we at
oh we always do yeah I know but I'll
tell you just super fast food the first
time I ever met him I've only met him a
few times he's always been very nice to
me but the first time I ever met him I
went to to Wild West Picture Show
the offices
yeah I did the festival he Peter
Billingsley carried me blacked out drunk
to my hotel room
I've also I've also done that with Peter
Billingsley oh by the way my uh
Christmas story is my favorite movie of
all time swingers is like in the top
three and I've befriended both of them
never told them either of them
peterbilsley carried in my room and made
jokes the entire way was carrying me
going nothing's for free buddy I'm
[__] here and Vince's sister carried
me she was the other like they had me
propped up and the next day I saw her
Vince I remember being a drive-through
in Vince was like buddy you want a
cheeseburger man because that's so
[__] up and uh his sister the next day
goes
oh are you okay honey Peter was being
such a [__] and I was like no that's
so funny and I was so embarrassed to see
Vince and I always saw him he goes he
goes ah what's up dude that was a
[__] party man he he's like us like
he's just like a dude like he thinks
he's so cool down there yeah anyway but
the first time I met him I went to
Picture Show the offices to meet Steve
Byrne to work on something
and uh
I got there and they go Steve's in
Vince's office just go in there playing
PlayStation and I like was like
yeah and I walked in they were playing
[__] hockey and we were playing
hockey on PlayStation
yeah
dude he's talking his assistant comes in
and goes Vince so and so called and
walks out and he goes there's a nice way
to do that there's a nice way to do that
I swear to God right and I'm like this
is insane he beats Steve do we have a
talk about this one here okay he beats
Steve and as me and Steve are walking
away to go to the other room to work
he's going
Steve man it's not about who won our
loss it's just we spend some time
together today
[__] guy
with this one
it was so I was like this is a dream
come true like yeah I can't believe I
met him he's playing [__] hockey
liking swingers right and he's talking
the same [__] isn't it weird how we
really find ourselves sometimes yeah
anyway all right
let's battle baby okay oh my butcher box
babies let's talk about butcher box uh
it's a service that delivers High
Quality Meats to your home every month
and you can customize it or you can go
with one of what they have uh and you
can stop at any time uh I love it you
don't have to worry about shopping for
for proteins when you're at the grocery
store which I actually don't do well
anyway uh it's all the best ingredients
as well it's 100 grass-fed beef it's
organic chicken it's a pork that's
raised crate free wild caught Seafood
all that kind of thing
um humanely raise no antibiotics no
hormones in their proteins get it right
to your doorstep free shipping in the
continental United States there is no
surprise fees whatsoever
um
what else what do I love about butcher
box I mean I get 14 pounds when it gets
delivered so you stock up and uh
it's like when you want when you want to
cook it's like you have options in the
fridge if I went to the supermarket I
would never buy that much meat at one
time but now that I do I just throw it I
set it I forget it and when I'm in the
mood for pork guess what I got that pork
um recipe inspiration guides tips and
hacks you could also uh they could
personalize it as well anyway butcher
box babes is offering our listeners one
of their best deals yet a 100 grass-fed
chuck roast and a whole organic chicken
free when you join plus an additional 20
off your first box man these deals are
it's almost like it's it's too good not
to try sign up today at butcherbox.com
tastebuds and use code taste buds to get
one a 100 grass-fed chuck roast and a
whole goddamn chicken excuse my language
free in the first box plus up to 20 uh
plus twenty dollars off okay so it's
butcherbox.com taste buds and then
you're gonna use the code taste buds to
get this special deal butcher box We
Love Rocket money here at taste buds uh
if you don't know what it is rocket
bunny was formerly known as true bill it
is a personal finance app that finds and
cancels all your unwanted subscriptions
monitor you're spending and helps you
lower your bills all in one place it is
an absolutely genius idea
when I heard I was like this is so great
there's no reason not to sign up for
this because one of the things that is
an issue for me and I feel like
everybody is you sign up for stuff and
you get recurring charges and over time
you don't remember what it was and you
can't find your passwords and you want
to like you know cancel subscriptions
and it's a whole rigmarole rigmarole is
a fun word over 80 percent of people
have subscriptions they forgot about
like a streaming service that you bought
just to watch one show that you never
use rocket money will quickly and easily
identify your subscriptions for you so
you stop paying for them
um you just hit cancel it's as easy as
that you don't want it you press cancel
they'll cancel it for you uh no calling
customer service no emailing okay over
three million people have used rocket
money saving them an average of up to
720 bucks yeah I saved 200 bucks myself
from two subscriptions that I did not
even know that I had just by downloading
the app it's as easy as that stop
throwing your money away cancel unwanted
subscriptions and manage your expenses
the easy way by going to rocketmoney.com
tastebuds that's rocketmoney.com taste
buds
I was you ready yeah are we doing the I
love
it's been too nice let's get salty baby
yeah now let's I love you all right yeah
yeah
no matter what happens I love you no
matter what happens I love you no matter
what happens I love you time for B
b-a-t-t-l-e bus I saw a couple on
Instagram do that chant at each other's
face no you didn't kiss on the lips and
then turn to watch the show no it was
one of the sweetest things I've ever
seen oh that's great they do the battle
fans are the best yeah they are and they
peck on the lips after and then they
turn to watch the show oh God that warms
my heart it destroyed me oh wow that's
so much fun I'm not in a state where I
can see things like that right now uh
anyway
uh all right what's the battle the I
forgot oh beef jerky versus Trail Mix
yeah
truck stops snacks
I love it truck stocks trucks stop
snacks I love a truck stop when I did my
Bronco road trip as you can imagine I
stopped in many truck stops
I'm sure you got combos at those right I
never got combo that's what you said you
got your combo but I did buy both of
these items okay uh and I know I know I
said I do bike but on this trip I wasn't
buying it I bought a lot it doesn't
matter don't we can't digress any
further the point is these are your two
[__] Mainstays at a truck stop I
would say that's it I mean you know Big
Dog they got your ICS you got your
Slurpee variations you got your soda
machine but if you're looking at the
snack yeah the stereotypical gastro gas
station truck stops now because I feel
like the other types of snacks meaning
like mini Donuts uh you know cake cake
snacks whatever no no no right like it's
salty this is protein bars protein
sustenance no no what I was going to say
though is like candy bar selection
whatever that varies from from truck
stop to truck stop yeah you know what I
mean you'll be like oh this place
doesn't have kids so you jerk whatever
it is always pork rinds whatever yeah
this is this is this is like you know uh
and now the brands may vary but these
are two things no matter what you know
jerky came into my life very late
how late jerky came into my life five
years ago what I never really I was
intimidated by jerky I didn't love the
smell of jerky a lot of times
um I didn't understand it like dry the
beef
put it in a bag salt the [__] out of it
and now I'm eating old dry chewy tough
beef and
I mean even in the name it's jerky
listen so I was intimidating jerky
became now jerky has exploded there's
like artisanal jerking I jerky now that
melts in my mouth so there is types of
jerky now that I I understand it's it's
it's I'll tell you what you don't know
about jerky there's a lot of sugar in it
if you don't get the right one you think
I don't know that okay I'm team jerky
you think I don't know that I don't like
how you pointed at me like you were
really taking me to class okay I'll tell
you what I window shopped jerky for
sugar content to make sure I'm not
getting the wrong stuff well let me tell
you something right now Jerky like I'll
tell you something you don't know you
ready for this yes it is try finding a
turkey jerky that doesn't have sugar
added to it I can't find it I can find a
sugarless beef I can't find a sugarless
turd this is not a strike against Sharky
huh isn't that a strike against turkey
about what you can't even find one that
doesn't have sugar in it I can find a
sugarless beef jerky right but you can't
find a sugarless turkey jerky well we're
not really arguing turkey jerky are we
oh
this is how deep I go with jerky let me
tell you something about jerky okay now
like I said five years I came into my
life I still if you buy the wrong jerky
you're like what am I doing here I mean
it's just you you have to grind you're
in sizes same thing with trail mix but
go ahead
and you know that I'm right trail mix is
never tough no no no no not tough you
buy the wrong trail mix it has like an
almost chemical taste to it where
there's like you're like this is not
something's wrong here okay let's let's
just so the jerk well jerky can have a
little bit of a weird taste too okay
well yeah sometimes your bag that
doesn't need to be refrigerated yeah
that's something's wrong and then you
open it open up and they got that packet
in there of chemicals yeah because
they're like God forbid the same packet
that you only the only other place you
find it is in your suitcase
yeah you find it in your goddamn luggage
it's like literal chemicals and they're
like we need these chemicals in here so
that the chemicals and not stay as fresh
chemicals
and then also it's like first of all
okay first of all like orange juice and
greeting cards I don't know where the
jerky people have the bowls of hitting
the price tags they do with the jerky
what are you talking about bottom line
jerky is 5.99 dude 7.99 a bottom line
jerky you're getting a high-end jerky
you're going 11.99 129 if you're in the
air Dave if you're in the airport with a
top-line jerk you can't you can't
airport us here you can't airport it but
I will say I will say I will say I will
say 99 for raises in the airport
the dichotomy I thought you know where I
find jerky in gas station truck stops
and at the airport is where I buy my
jerky the most okay and so I'm looking
at the same jerky I'm looking I'm paying
14.99 but I'm telling you something hold
on a second hold on a second 990 let's
call the median price on jerky 9.99 and
I think that's the medium I think I'm
being liberal okay but I agree let's say
nine let's call it 9.99
Bob it's a bag of steak how much do you
want it to cost I mean you're buying a
bag of steak let me come in right there
you're not buying a bag of steak just
because it's in a bag doesn't mean
you're buying a bag of steak because my
other gripe with jerky is after you open
that and you peel and you pop in there
there's four and a half pieces of jerky
in there it's 9.99 jerkies nah dude you
got to be honest with me right jerky
bags are never plump they never ample
you open that [__] up you take a couple
of bites especially if the bigger pieces
and you look back in you're like oh my
God I got a ration this year I gotta be
honest with you I fine you have to
ration just I I disagree I find that
that jerky bag offers me a a wealth of
jerky way more than I can ever finish in
one sitting oh Joe I'm dead serious
I'll give you it when it's when it's
truthful but you you my problem with
little jerky goes a long way my problem
with jerky is that you're not getting a
second helping out of jerky you're not
unless you're buying a motherload bag I
mean but your typical bag is talking I'm
talking Jack Links I'm talking chick
clicks yeah I'm talking not Jacqueline
this doesn't get a bigger laugh that
doesn't get a bigger level I'm doing the
the emblem of Jaclyn to you nothing that
was good nothing it was good nothing I
mean I think you're giving it a little
too much credit I think all right Jesus
if I did that on stage if I went do you
ever buy Jack Links it's all the house
down no I've never done it but I have it
Jerry Stiller would have loved it
um that's my I open it and then you look
at I swear to god dude this what are you
getting at it six pieces hops tops
did you with a friend nobody's ever
shared jerky I don't know what you're I
don't know how you're running your jerky
I have never bought it you heard the
sentence listen nobody's ever shared
jerky you heard it and you know what I
heard it back to his old tricks you know
why you heard it because these are two
of the loneliest Foods on planet Earth
trail mix and jerky are meant to be in
the world it's for the nomaders yeah
yeah it is it is but I'll tell you right
now I'll tell you right now I got if I
have three friends there I'm still big
dick Swinging with my trail mix
everyone's getting a piece that trail
mix bag is like like it's like it's like
a sock full of pennies all right
you are getting the value for a trim
which you are getting the value out of
that bag you want it that bag is heavy
bro that big it's like you can play
cornhole with that bag don't you dare
you can play cornhole no don't can't
play cornhole with a bag of jerky sound
don't you that's it you could quote me
on that you can't play cornhole with a
bag of sugar don't you dare you want to
talk about price points jerky what I
mean sorry trail mix what are its two
main ingredients dried fruit and nuts
nothing on this [__] planet in a
supermarket is more marked up than nuts
the the sack of the price point on a
pistachio is insane cashews the Mainstay
of your precious trail mix yeah but
that's cash is a big money babe dude
cashews raisins you're paying and maybe
some M M's they throw in don't leave out
the chocolate okay and maybe some MMS
this is the beauty but this is the
beauty of a trail mix right your trail
mix bag you and you know it as well as I
do your trail mix bag nine times out of
ten it's that skinny
[Music]
easy easy 5.99 even 5.99 for what it is
is I I think I think it has an audition
that's got a lot more calorie in that
it's got a lot more uh weight by volume
it's got a lot more you know maybe not
as much protein but listen to me here's
the thing about the trail mix you know
how you just like well we're not talking
about turkey jerky we're talking about
beef jerky the beauty of a trail mix is
you could have your own trail mix recipe
so could I you never know what you can
interrupt it
don't talk to me like that you
you might have some nuts peanuts cashews
whatever you might have some raisins you
might have some M M's but you don't know
what you're gonna get in there you might
have some dried cherries in there that's
big money too listen to me you might see
a checks and you're talking you might
see some checks you might see some
pretzels you're talking you're talking
what about the Sesame stick you're
talking I'll take you to school on your
own on your own team stack right now
okay you're talking rookie trail mix in
my opinion trail mix to me the whole
point is to get a snack that's filling
that isn't bad for you and everything
five of the seven ingredients you just
mentioned whatever the number was the
majority of the ingredients you just
mentioned are all the things I avoid if
I see a trail mix with Chex Mix in it I
don't buy it well that's something
that's the borderline I don't buy it my
trail mix is nuts and fruit yes dried
cherries in a trail mix
tell it to take a walk because dried
cherries that aren't sugared taste like
[__] so you just added you just added a
candy bar level of sugar to yourself I
don't think there's a bit of dried fruit
than a dried cherry
if it's sugared if it's not sugared it's
it's the sour do you ever do you ever
dried cranberry that doesn't have sugar
added to it yeah it's a war zone dude
yeah it's horrible it's [__] horrible
man all right you know so you got to go
raisins which usually don't have sugar
at it and you add it to nuts maybe a
variety of nuts you know and then you do
your own salting and then you've got a
wonderful snack you're getting enough
sweetness from the raisins you're
getting salty and crunch from the nuts
that's what's going on there but there's
no better flavor combination to the
human Palace than sweet and salty we
live off of it but jerky straight salts
don't that's how dare you okay you're
right how dare you Teriyaki is almost
taken over as the primary jerky Mommy
that's not sweet teriyaki yeah it's
absolutely sweet that's why it's bad for
you to get teriyaki sauce on your
chicken it's like sugar yeah yeah yeah
but it's it's like it's not sweet in the
way of a raisin or a chocolate sweet in
like a it's literally sweet in exactly
the way of raising
I'm like oh this is sweet oh dude I
think you're I think it's uh generally
sweet they add pineapple juice
yeah you get you got something coming
through there but here's what I'm saying
you buy a bag of jerky even though he's
only getting six bites you're eating
it's got six bytes six pieces okay and
those pieces are big
I don't know man dude you want to reach
it in there you're fiddling around
behind that chemical bag you're pulling
out pieces that are just like that big
your hands dude there's nothing better
than the shake dude it's like a bag of
weed you go we're all out of weed then
you go look at all the shake at the
bottom you got beef Shake
it's crazy what are you talking about I
wish I could sprinkle it on salads you
got beef Shake is not appetizing tell me
this much tell me you wouldn't love to
do this tell me you would love to take
that beef shake and drop it into a trail
mix now you tell me that wouldn't be me
we may have stumbled off or something
here because I don't know if I've ever
seen a jerky in a trail mix no if you
had raisins beef jerky shavings and nuts
in a trail mix I mean you could live off
that yeah you could live well here's
here's the criticism I'll give uh to
beef jerky that I don't think trail mix
has right beef jerky you buy it and it's
the same bite you're eating one thing
through the whole thing trail mix by
nature is is a mix and depending on if
you go in just reach in you don't know
what flavor what what what fistful uh
what's gonna be flavor heavy in that
fistful and I like that sometimes I'm
getting way more raisins sometimes I'm
getting way more chocolate sometimes
it's an equal balance and so I never
know and also I truly don't I also can
actually consume it the way I like as
well so if I don't want to leave it up
to the random scoop I could be like I'm
just having a raisin and chocolate right
now I'm actually gonna have just some M
M's right now I swear to you I'm not
just saying this it is the God's honest
truth
that is my least favorite thing about
trail mix
and when I make my trail mix at home
I I'm painfully careful to have it be
equal parts everything for everybody can
I put into it yeah
and then I put it into a bowl that has
enough birth that every time I reach in
I'm getting the same ratio every time I
I hate when I reach in and I get all
nuts are all raised I can't I don't mind
it because it makes a Next Bite a whole
mystery and maybe maybe it comes back
around you know what I like when I'm
eating and it's it's there's no
chocolate right I'm chewing and I'm
getting some dried fruit I'm getting
some raisin I'm getting some nut I take
three or four bites everything's
breaking down in there and I think
there's gonna be no chocolate in there
and then boom there was a random m m in
there and at the end of a very fruity
nutty bite at the very tail end I get
hit with the notes of chocolate and I
didn't know even though it was going to
be in there and that's it's taking you
through a journey every time you put it
in your mouth you don't know what to
expect every time you chew god plain
playing Eminem suck
this is go this is I've always been you
know I know they don't I I know what you
mean they do I know what you mean to be
thrown into a [__] trail mix to be
worth something like they're so boring
that's why the people I know what you
mean but God's honest I know because I
know what you mean because I would think
that too we tend to think that but if
there's a bag Eminem's up there and you
poured somebody handed through in your
mouth you're like
it's just it's just bad when you compare
it to a pen on Eminem you feel like it's
lacking something but Eminem something
about that candy it's a taste on its own
the plain m m it's not just like you're
eating chocolate I find it boring I find
it sad it's up there with the Hershey
Kiss but but but here it's in a mix so
why is that even a thing I'm just
sidetracking into how much Eminem sucks
so bad that they that they've basically
become famous for having a place as part
of Trail Mix
that is I mean they are famous for so
much M Ms and that's just I think the
peanuts I think the peanut m m took the
birth of Peter Eminem took them up the
ladder truly and you know and after that
it was all it was all commercials and
gags uh I honestly don't know if there's
a more iconic arguably
a more iconic uh chocolate
like a pat like we will argue if it's a
candy bar or not but Eminem's is I mean
you can't get more iconic playing Eminem
you can't get more Hershey a Hershey bar
to me is nearly the same as another
person Hershey's the Yankees I mean her
she is I would think the Eminem's are
right there the Hershey Company it's the
same thing uh M Ms or are they the Mars
company I think they're Mars and we
shouldn't digress too much in there yeah
okay but I feel like I feel like
Eminem's entire game it's like
is is the commercials you got you got
one running around with lipstick and
heels on and it's and it's supposed to
be funny did they just ban her
um
they ended the characters or something
yeah it's a marketing thing I have no
idea I love chocolate and heels so uh
you ever on a plane you're on a plane
and all of a sudden you could tell
somebody opened a bag of jerky somewhere
because the goddamn smell is so
intrusive and I'll tell you right now
depending depending on the flavor of
jerky too it could waft over and
actually be like unpleasant
I'm not going to say that when you first
open a bag of jerky there might be a bit
of a of a waft because you're opening a
bag of protein anytime you open any
sealed protein like properly sealed
protein you get a waft or something
anytime you open a properly seal product
that's true I mean I I know you don't do
a lot of cooking for yourself no all
right I do a lot of cooking for myself
yes when I buy fish or you buy whatever
you buy wrapped food or protein when you
open it sure you'll get a little smell
of something but we're agreeing and so
what I'm saying is it's like but you're
not smelling it in a [__] plane
across three aisles I am though I'm not
and I'll tell you what jerky is one of
those things when you open it and it's
yours it's fine but if somebody next to
me open like a jerky and I'm on the
plane I'm just like
let's close the jerky bro I don't want
to smell you a jerky I think that's a
wild accusation you're making right now
but it's not an accusation it's my
experience I don't believe your
experience I believe you made it up wow
wow you don't think I've been sitting
next to yourself you're not above lying
you don't think
and then I've been on a plane and sat
next to somebody open jerky and was like
ah next to somebody fine but you made it
sound like they were they were you know
you were in coach and they were you
don't think I smell jerky that wasn't
from the person next to me no I don't
you're insane bro I don't you're insane
I don't if jerky's got a two-seat jump
that's it the open jerky V is eight feet
from you okay if the open jerky right
now you don't think you'd smell it are
you nuts are you cuckoo bananas that's a
little farther than a two seat jump to V
right now no way if I'm in if this is
one row and I look up she's four rows
back no you're not you're crazy
she is she would she you would smell
you're also in a all right well I was
gonna say we're in a closed room I mean
Rose a plane is also a closed space
but no I don't think I would no I just
don't think I would smell it I think
that's I think that's nutty we could
easily put this to the test man we could
easily put it to the test all right so
the fans are chiming in that uh jerky's
a chewing issue that hurts his job
yeah actually bro how old are the fans
forget about it if you have any like
caps and calves that's that's that you
work for jerky sometimes you feel it in
your jaw you're gonna be picking your
trail mix you're going to be picking
your trail mix out of your teeth no
there's no popcorn kernels in there or
something the chocolate the the dried
fruit that dried fruit gets stuck in
your teeth dude it gets stuck in your
molars it gets stuck I normally would
agree with you but since you've got
since you got the other stuff in there
it kind of is like a natural it kind of
like all gets together and I don't
really get I don't have a problem
getting dried fruit stuck in my teeth
they claim that some almonds are doing a
natural irrigation process that's why
you're chewing that's wild I do
those almonds get broken up they get
Shard like they help break the [__] down
all right all right I'll tell you right
now that's what was one of my first
things I said about the jerky though is
that like if you get a tough jerky it's
almost like but conversely I'll give you
a jerky that melts in your mouth is
pretty [__] good
but a tough of course a tough jerky is
like but a tough jerk listen it's like
you're eating a leather shoe we go down
this road a lot a tough jerky is the
same thing as the chemical tasting trail
mix that I'm talking about there's a
terrible version of everything out there
we're not talking about a tough jerky
we're talking about beef jerky in the
way it's supposed to be served up okay
so let me ask you this then let's go on
an evil even playing field right
I'm not talking about vegetarians people
that eat meat people that eat meat when
you get jerky and it's like soft and oh
dude when it's like tobacco chewy
tobacco consistency
it's Heavenly well I don't want to get
started on sodium so I'll pause but your
trail mix is no walking Department I
know that I know that but I think that
the jerky is
it's a problem like high blood pressure
like I think jerky's sodium is an issue
you have your sodium content for the day
I can't argue that I can't look red meat
is also not great for you know but can I
ask you this yeah
I'm not talking about vegetarians just
the natural person that that'll eat meat
right why why then is jerky polarizing
and trail mix is not there's way more
people that are like I love jerky or I
hate jerky don't give me jerky why are
there so many people that have a disdain
for jerky I've never met one person as a
disdain for it unless they just don't
eat oh yeah no no I see people like oh I
don't no this no because it is there's
something about dried meat like you're
weirdly walking around with a bag of
jerking at an airport offering it to
people I don't understand no there's
something about there's something about
dried aged salted room temperature meat
in a bag right that people I love steak
I love burger no I don't eat turkey I
don't eat turkey but I've never heard of
a person that doesn't like trail mix
unless you got a peanut I'll give you
the excuse me I will give you the
unrefrigerated meat argument
when it comes to something very
processed like um like a slim jim okay I
get it somebody goes beef stick God
that's ugh what's in it and that's so
bad for you and it says Fine beef jerky
in a bag that is no weirder than tuna in
a can it's no weirder than that that's
very weird I don't like tuna I don't
like eat I know but that's one of my big
issues with tuna when we did tuna salad
versus egg salad I told you it's odd
that I'm eating a tuna fish that died
nine years ago that's fine but my point
is is people don't even bat an eye at a
can of tuna and then go oh beef jerky
you know it's weird it's like is it
weird is it that weird it's cured meat
dude when you go to a high-end
Steakhouse they're curious their age
stuff yeah their age stuff is in an
unrefrigerated room it's not
refrigerated but it's not in a bag at
the deli well it's doesn't matter it's
cured it's that's what a cured meat is
you know like so you know when people go
and there's a there's there's trail mix
and there's jerky I think more people
are going to be grabbing for the trail
mix I think that's what I'm trying to
say I just think and I think does the
does like
does the does the population lie
I think that people go for one or the
other me myself in all honesty I often
go for both
my airport meal a lot of the time
because I don't want to I try to avoid
eating the bad stuff or overpaying for
something that's so lackluster yes can
you just tell him we'll be we'll be done
in a minute I just feel I feel bad okay
okay okay okay I just want oh yeah so so
my uh notice how he interrupts during my
I'm sorry it's been it's been in the
back of my head and I just feel bad all
right yeah
you can continue exactly where you are
all right fair enough yeah
my go-to airport meal because I don't
want to overpay for lackluster crap I'm
not gonna I I get furious when it's like
I just paid 38 and I got two terrible
eggs and some bacon yeah
and then my go-to what I really want to
get is like I want to get the McDonald's
I want to get the Burger King
but it's true as I go I'm going to get
my money's worth at least I'm gonna get
what I'm paying for it's gonna taste
good and I try to do that anymore
because it's bad for me so my go-to meal
often an airport is a bag of beef
jerking a bag of Trail Mix I do both
um however
I don't think that most people go for
either of these things if I'm being
honest and here's why I think that
airport meals if you're still a commoner
like me I know you're
you know
but the comments yes you will remind
them those of us that still ride and
Coach maybe once in a while we could
afford to pay for extra leg room
uh the middle-aged man that's been
saving money since 14. I make no
apologies for Comfort when I fly okay
that's fine
oh good for you all right when you
there's no first class available
I flew in coach for 40 years man no
listen all right so have I I'm still
there
uh because I don't forget I don't forget
no I'm kidding listen
here's the point
meals as you know in coach class have
become you just select from that
terrible menu they offer you now
I am astounded but I think it speaks to
how little people eat either of these
things that adoption
is not beef jerky or trail mix you would
think these Airlines would go look
instead of offering these half-assed
Bento boxes that have like three pieces
of sharp cheese and a grape or whatever
they would be like yeah we got a bag of
Trail Mix or a bag of beef jerky and it
never goes bad
what's this you're not putting out that
kind of money
it's expensive expensive you're on the
plane charge me 12.99 for a bag of beef
jerky oh oh charger okay I got you got
you I thought you meant like I said no
I'm saying like the meals you can buy
it's like it's always like they might
not do it because that plane's gonna
stink if everybody gets to beef jerky
they don't have the trail mix either
though
they have like The Artisan box and it'll
be like you know three of those water
crack Crest crap whatever I know I hate
it well why is it called jerky
because it's funny
jerky
I'll tell you one thing I've seen like
like literally like Mom and Pop like
artisanal beef jerky stores like where
you go in and there's like a menu of it
yeah those are pretty [__] dope
there's one at the uh Ponce City Market
I believe in Atlanta I mean shout out
yeah jerky variety is no joke I mean
dude have you had bacon jerky
it's unreal yeah it's unreal I mean you
want to talk sodium yeah but dude I
don't want it it's a bag of bacon yeah
yeah
it's good it's real good we won't even
get into the health implications because
I think I got you there with trail mix
you gotta look at the woman mine I got
some fruit in line listen yeah you do
you do but your sugar intake is much
higher and carbs
and carbs you got me there yeah we
should go to the phones yeah let's wrap
it up wanna go to the phones where do
you guys stand in this debate uh beef
jerky
there you go it's polarizing I told you
but V's like hate is a strong word gen Z
you know what does that matter our taste
buds are biological evolutionary I don't
know she sees meat and she just works
here falls for the animals that
sacrifice themselves it does have
diversity that's all about it
uh all right what do we got pimp uh one
fan writes in jerky's a little too close
to the consistency of my grandfather's
ball sack don't ask me how I know that
because again that's a chewy leathery
thing I told you come on uh trail mix is
the over the pants hand job of snacks
that's supposed to be good or bad bad
that's funny I'll take it anyway that's
funny because I get that
book dude you're already getting carbs
and a [__] little sugar eat some [__]
eat some Skittles or something yeah you
know like you might as well just dive in
at that point yeah but honestly that's
why I make my honestly someone says to
me you got two options nothing or an
over the pants I go give me that over
the pants I'll tell you what you know
what I do in the airport yeah you know
the air I won't even buy the pre-mixed
trail mix because they put so much sugar
make it yourself I buy a bag of nuts and
I buy a bag of raisins and I mix them
you like trail mix so much that you're
manufacturing yourself I like trail mix
I never said I didn't I'm just taking I
would take beef jerky over it because to
me I am fascinated by the concept you
could buy actual meat in that steak it's
weird about that and eat it I think it's
I think it's fascinating that's what I'm
saying it's meat in a certain state
the sentence you just said would you
find spam to be a blessing yes okay
you defend spam at another time then put
it on a t-shirt I find Spanish
no one has ever shared beef jerky these
are the two nuggets for today from
DeRosa no one has ever shared beef jerky
and I find spam to be a blessing
um I imagine beef jerky looks like the
skin on mummies in Egypt oh that's
interesting that's that's true though
honestly the the texture both in both in
your mouth and into your hand and the
visual of jerky is also very unpleasant
it's something you have to get over
I don't think it's that extreme but yes
with some imagination
imagination generational holleration or
opinionation opinion okay I thought it
was imagine
imagination yeah yeah give us one more
of each for each team pimp
a lot of people are kind of saying uh
trail mix is a concierge service that
caters to your tastes that's what I'm
saying [__] off guys I'm saying [__] off
these are my words you know you could do
you go and you get the bag you'd be like
I'm eating just chocolate right now I'm
eating just fruit right now and I'm
eating just nuts right now it really is
versatile
uh beef jerky's overrated glorified boot
leather
sure all right give us one more this a
trail mix though against trail mix let's
see you probably can't find this Trail
I'm gonna take this trail mix feels too
much like reaching under the couch
cushion for a snack it's funny that's
fun I give that I'll give that to win I
bet you that is trail mix on the couch
that's yeah that's that's a that's like
that's I would do that as a bit on stage
that's good that was good
that's a f that's a great Insight yeah
give that to win who is it pimp uh at I
am Dr Nick all right all right uh you
see our plugs up top
uh let's just go right to it because we
got another episode to do uh and see who
won a little humble pie here here we go
drumroll
how many votes how many votes the loser
with 39 there's uh 8 000 votes right now
61 to 39. 39 is trail mix yes
I am in shock I am in pure shock
especially because the phones were jerky
uh hating heavy
I can't believe that I can't believe
that wow that really that really opens
my eyes I I no it really does I never
ever I would have put money that trail
mix would beat jerky in a popular con uh
competition season three here I come wow
wow and that was handily 61 we're gonna
win season three I'm calling it now and
by the way I I don't wanna I can't it's
not locked in
but
I have been contacted by a manager of a
McDonald's on Long Island and she is
checking with the team to see if we are
allowed to go in there and videotape no
no doing like a two-hour shift amazing
so she's amazing she's checking and she
she said they reacted positively to it
amazing but it needs to be quick shout
out to Entenmann's I think we mentioned
them yeah I mentioned them they're all
about a pound loaf I mentioned that
recently sent me they sent me a case
t-shirt a water bottle and a phone
charger entrance come on what come on
you want do you want some yeah
yeah come on
I bring their chocolate cake to events
and demons if you're watching and we
know that you are you sent me the case
of the old butter butter pound loaf you
gotta you gotta spread the love you got
an Entenmann's t-shirt do you know a
gangster that is nobody's got an
intimacy it's a box of the eight
chocolate donuts that says check out my
eight pack
Entenmann's come on guys well I love
Intimates no I'm not saying you don't
yeah no but thank you but how many times
have I showed up at your house right
yeah because we're having a little get
together with announcements and I've
brought a chocolate cake entrance and a
raspberry twist a couple times a couple
times yeah
all right uh I still love you baby I
love you too
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food
who's gonna fight but only one food can
be right taste buds man yeah they're
coming to them